I had a buddy who I spoke with the other
day and we actually
he sent in a text and I want to read
that message Theo to follow up on our
conversation earlier this week I'm
filing for divorce from my wife after
seven years of marriage pretty damn
scary but have been so unhappy in the
relationship for the past several years
and tried to convince myself that it was
best for a young child to suck it up I
truly gave it all I had but finally
realized life was just too short to not
be happy
coming from the south I don't have tons
of friends who have gone through divorce
that I can reach out to but know that
the percentage is high even at like 50
percent was hoping to get some positive
stories from your listeners about life
after divorce especially when involving
a child regaining one's identity Finding
Love Again being a single parent
Etc my fellow is getting divorced
congratulations it sounds like you know
that's kind of what he wanted to do I
went through something real similar well
I said but I went through this exact
thing about eight years ago had a two
have two children with my ex-wife and uh
the best piece of advice that I got was
understand that being the best father
you can be your your ex-wife is going to
benefit from that I think a lot of us
that get divorced try to be the best
that we can be but kind of lay this
Gauntlet down of like you know we don't
want to we don't wanna be nice or give
anything to the ex-wife uh because most
of the time you know we get divorced
because things didn't go the way uh you
know we thought they would wow that's
really uh Paul I appreciate that that's
that seems insightful you know he
doesn't seem like he's thinking about
himself as much he's just saying be it
the best dad you can be and that's
actually going to benefit your partner
there let's hear a little bit more
anyhow that was one thing just uh she's
gonna benefit be cool with that accept
that make friends with that uh and just
be consistent Mike's wife and I were not
on good terms for about three three and
a half years a long time she was a
complete and utter and um you know
see you next Tuesday baby that's what
they call them sometimes
um we're you know just consistency year
after year and man honestly now I could
say she's she's you know one of my
better friends and we have a great
co-parenting relationship which
obviously benefits the kids greatly
which I'm sure uh you know this guy
wants
wow you know this and that's some
selfless that's some selfless suggestion
right there and that's the thing don't
be thinking about you think about the
child
and think about being helpful to your
ex-wife because being helpful to your
ex-wife is actually in turn being
helpful to your child
now hopefully you don't get one of them
ex-wife's just out there dragging you
into the mud and beating you in the neck
with that money stick
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one